thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a defensive
wild ride with Stevo I've been attacked
I've been attacked all over the place uh
most notably by my old buddy bam and uh
and he did so in a rap song oh this rap
song it was very personal he attacked my
skateboarding and uh not only do I
address this in today's episode I
actually
respond to all kinds of negative
comments you know like people read mean
tweets it's interesting so we did a
little bit of that then we got into
current events and it turns out there's
actually aliens can you believe that I
mean easier to believe than to care
about it would seem but yeah and um more
current events and then on the back half
of this episode I think every single one
of us reveals something very uh personal
like Paul's addiction to to magic
mushrooms turns out that he's taking
these things every single day I can't
even believe it and uh and and Scott
Randolph like that wait and see Scott
Randolph try to convince you that it was
a bad experience having the doctor put
fingers up his butt not convincing me
pal anyway we got a lot to get into so
let's get into it
so are we just going we're ready with
negative comments
um yeah I have them on my phone
all right you want to start with that I
think that the title of this podcast is
Stevo responds to brutal negative
comments including bams
well let's start with bam while I pull
some up what the fam comments are you
talking about I mean he attacked me are
we have we started this personal way
yeah oh ladies and gentlemen us ladies
and gentlemen me and Scott Randolph the
gorgeous Paul Briskey and skinny Vinny
yeah dude yeah we're we're back on
current events and nothing's more
current than the personal attack I
suffered from Bam Margera who released a
majorly produced rap song she was fire
as [__] dude yeah so well produced so
well done the energy he put into it
unbelievable where were you when you got
the the note like bam responses people
were you like uh what is this [__]
guy have to say now okay the rap song
came to my attention long before it was
on TMZ I just responded once it was on
TMZ why when when did you hear about it
I did I heard about it ages ago because
I get my news from Reddit now
yeah yeah wow yeah I mean I don't check
it as much nearly as I was for a minute
there sure but like every week or two
did you hear it when we were in the UK
yeah I think I I think I did yeah okay I
mean they only released the whole song
like in the last week or so yeah okay so
you saw the teaser yeah all the teasers
yeah yeah I saw when bam was actually in
the studio was that a studio in rehab
in uh La I think
now
because Australian Mumble rappers
for uh
you know making a wave and riding it
that's the crew that he did the song
with yeah because you really think it's
the kind of wave you want to ride
I mean when you're at that frequency
that bams that yeah I mean I don't know
that it was a great way for bam to ride
but I think that as far as these rappers
from Australia I think that they got
they got some some publicity some
exposure why is he mad at Wee Man
because he escapes he's mad he's mad at
Wee Man for uh being a pro skateboarder
probably because we man and I had the
collab skateboard and the last time I
was in contact with bam I was like kind
of making a big deal out of uh Wee Man
and I uh competing like Escape
right making a competition out of a
filming skateboarding to promote our
board yeah but bam had the chance to do
that too right but Bam's not big on
um making more than five dollars a board
in sales well I mean yeah he had the
opportunity to do that like I I
presented it to him like let's um you
know let's get on track let's
be sober let's be productive let's let's
do all this great stuff and we can make
a ton of money selling skateboards but
um that didn't pan out and so bam got
mad at me selling skateboards instead
damn and so you responded on TMZ
I'm selling boards I recorded my
response for TMZ they got it up in
lightning speed same day yeah and then I
put my response on Tick Tock and I saw
it just go you know tick tock's the
stuff either like really really takes
off or it just doesn't do anything and
this one kind of took off and so I
thought okay
let me put that on Instagram and
Facebook
um
and and uh I think it performed all
pretty well not so has there been any
response back from bam no
do you think there will be or do you
have to hit him back to back
yeah like there's nothing like serious
about it I mean you're not mad at them
I'm not mad at him at all I just think
it's funny plus
um dude just today
I uh put a story because we're building
the ramp in my backyard and I put up a
story with my goats and the ramp saying
that since uh this personal attack now
I'm building a ramp when in fact I've
been building it yeah I've been like
planning on building this ramp for weeks
and for months
um but that story with the goats and the
ramp in two hours it's uh over a hundred
thousand opens wow I don't know that
I've ever had that much eyeballs on a
story
yeah so Bam's hooking you up Babe's
hooking me up yeah this is this Lux
brought up that you know you are a
rapper as well and you could respond
with it
right but here's the thing I I
um made a video about my rap career
like how many people have we had on this
podcast where we brought up my rap
career not one of them remembers or knew
that I had a rap career and you're
underground right so like it's just not
something that's so common knowledge now
I will resurrect it
I will I will resurrect it oh my God I
shouldn't even say this but but there
was a a thread a text thread between
some of the jackass guys
and uh we were like text dropping into
the text thread videos that we filmed
selfie videos of us rapping
like out of response
you know to bam yeah I mean stuff that
will never go anywhere never ever see
the light of day but I was like you know
oh my God I mean what did you say at
least can you say what you said yeah
let's hear those Rhymes
let's hear those you should do like a
vinyl pressing of your rap album like
some like a prestigious like crack
cocaine yeah I've got it pulled up here
on discogs.com
um you down with STDs
okay where all right uh I don't even
know what
who did the art for that album
[Music]
yeah dude you gotta know I'm totally rad
I just don't know why that makes it so
mad
okay
[Music]
and this is why I poke the push until I
die but you just cry all you do is lie I
tell you that your bone spurs is cat
cap is whack you get in the octagonal
make you tap
yeah that's pretty good fighting words
Steve yeah
now he has to choose he could probably
beat me up yeah maybe right uh okay so
uh so again we're just we're not like
being malicious for me and it's just you
know having a laugh
um always wished for bam to get healthy
and be good and and all these things but
since we're on the subject of personal
attacks
an idea that we've floated around is to
hit me with brutal negative comments
and uh I will respond have you still
been pretty good on not looking at
comments I'm really good okay so these
are these are gonna be the first time
you hearing these right where'd you pull
these off of the main channel the the
podcast YouTube channel okay like I on
scheduled the last YouTube video the one
the stunts I regret just because the
promo was just like I mean it was
comically like heavy like you know and
again go to stevo.com and buy merch like
but I was sensitive about that I don't I
do not want to look at the comments on
that video because they're just gonna be
like mad at me for promoting the merch
yeah
okay so like I mean it's not like there
are like the meanest comments ever that
even exists I was looking for mean ones
like there's a lot of that make fun of
your voice right there's a lot of
negativity on the Zack ass podcast okay
which we have addressed but this one
stuck out so she couldn't just give the
guy a question instead just Grill him
and then bring someone else on to steal
the spotlight Vinnie which was
my fault so that uh yeah I mean we
addressed that yeah okay well I'm just
telling you what I mean did you go to
that podcast to find that
I looked yeah there's not there's not uh
comments about the Zach podcast living
on on a different episode no no people
forget about it on that podcast okay I
mean honestly this is going to be a
little anticlimactic none of them are
like so bad that it's like funny or
really gonna hurt your feelings I think
the ones that that are relative to this
would be like on the BAM podcast like
you're taking advantage of bam you know
using them to make money but it's like
there'll be a million of those comments
on this one just because we're talking
about bam yeah yeah so here's one on the
bam what the one where Amazon on the
podcast you guys are talking about bam
so he's like in the title and thumbnail
sump thumbnail thumbnail
Stevo acts like he's your friend and
then he makes a public video to all his
fans public talking about your meth
abuse bro I did not
call him a methodic I said it was
alleged
yeah so yeah people you know feel like
you what would I mean what do you think
like yeah what are you gonna do man I've
done everything in my power to be the
best bro for bam I mean even even like
uh with the whole board thing it's like
he didn't want to do it it's like okay
well we're gonna set up a trust for your
kid we'll donate all of them or give all
the money to to Phoenix right it's still
a no even people payments right or like
child support payments I was like you
know what you're gonna get nailed with
uh the courts for an alimony child
support anyway just like put put this
aside from that like it would all
that's coming out of your pocket anyway
so let's just uh divert some money to
that and and the suggestion was so
offensive that's the last time I spoke
with Pam I think that he was mad at that
yeah how dare you what was his response
to that like how he was so drunk dude
how dare you yeah he kind of wasn't
getting it okay your podcast with Wee
Man has a lot of negative comments okay
because you took a hard stance against
video games in that podcast and The
Gamers spoke up so this one came from
Jim sin 2506. he said Stevo you're
awesome but if you're analogy about
video games is correct are we just
wasting our time watching your podcast
almost all of your fans play games if
you think like that then everything is a
waste of time if you're not making money
out of it yeah the gamers is a big
Community dude I'm a gamer myself uh
Call of Duty guy I will that's a soldier
I I will give that to him and I thought
that that was very uh constructively
worded it wasn't an attack it was like
Hey you know yeah and and and and hey
man if people enjoy video games
have at it you know I I while away time
watching stupid Netflix
Scott you haven't always been a gamer
right no I mean I used to play video
games when I was a kid but then I just
needed an outlet to like not look at my
phone for an hour and it's done a really
good job to like where I'll just forget
about time there's a lot of what do you
guys what's that you're just trying to
get you're trying to get your eyes away
from the screen so you go to the TV no
not the screen my work emails because I
can't turn it off emails so it's like
the work emails it's like there's no
turning off of me so if I'm sitting
there watching TV I'm looking at it but
if I'm playing Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 you're in the zone I'm in the
zone he's cutting down on screen time
yeah yeah
I mean everywhere you look I mean I'm
looking at screens or you know I think
that's just the reality of life now
you're just you're looking at screens
everywhere you go yeah so yeah I feel
like people
have every right to waste their time
however they want and like
some people do spend too much time
playing video games and it does have a
negative effect same as Netflix same as
YouTube same as
porn same as everything most people have
a pretty healthy relationship with and
just do it for fun I'm a super phone
addict dude like uh on your phone I mean
I don't know like just stupid Instagram
or like whatever I could be way more
productive if I uh had boundaries around
my screen time on my phone when you're
looking at Instagram you're looking at
what other people do are you looking at
like how your stuff is doing uh probably
mostly that yeah you think you have an
unhealthy relationship with Instagram
and social media and stuff yeah yeah
like Instagram for you is probably not a
healthy you don't even want it to open
you like hate it but like you can't look
away you know what I mean are there any
sort of programs for like I'm sure video
games
where they have like video game rehab
and stuff really yeah but are you are
you really telling me that there's not
more like a vitriolic hate why is it
that every time I go into a comment
section I end up with my feelings hurt I
don't know maybe you should have pulled
these because I think back in the day
like people were just like you know
Steve's talking over the guess but like
those have kind of stopped and I think
most of like the hate comments are like
all the ads and Bam but that's I I've
never really seen yeah people hate on
the ads but it's like bro what are you
we're trying to make money like how do
you think we're doing yeah people are
hitting on the ads just don't I think
it's people hating on the ads don't pay
for YouTube so they have to see our ads
and then the [__] ads that you'd get
when you don't pay for a subscription on
YouTube don't we um
no mid-roll ads on the podcast no it's
just our own ads yeah there's no
mid-roll there's no I think it's
literally fast forward the [__] yeah
anybody who's hating on the ad reads for
the podcast like they're they're
probably like fans
of mine who don't listen to other
podcasts that don't understand that
that's every podcast in the world yeah
that makes sense sometimes more we only
have three like something
but can't they just fast forward yeah
and don't you have the bookmarks now uh
yeah yeah now yeah so now it's on
YouTube at least it's how many comments
sorry I just did it so this is a great
cut to be like speaking of ads have you
heard of that yeah
and when it comes to the ads on this
podcast man I stand by the products I
promote take fume for example this is a
device that I always have in my pocket
because I love it and what's it for it's
for replacing bad habits with good ones
and it's got uh a core in here which
flavors air so you can trade in
addicting chemicals and drugs with
flavored air you can trade in
electronic gizmos with just this nicely
weighted device
I use it all the time I love it and I'm
not even trying to trade in a bad habit
I just picked up this good one it's fume
baby and if you've got a dirty bad habit
that you want to drop and replace with
the fume I got good news for you because
if you go to
tryfume.com and use the promo code Stevo
you can get 10 off your journey pack why
is it called a journey pack because it's
the beginning of a journey to a
healthier you with less bad habits and
more good habits if you see me in person
ask me hey you got your fume in your
pocket and I bet you I will if I don't
I'll make a little Shout Out video for
you on your phone how about that yeah
that offer is good until the end of the
year and the offer for 10 off the
journey pack I don't know how long that
lasts so hurry up and go to
trifum.com and use the promo code Stevo
now let's get back to it
I was gonna say how many comments are
there like as telling me that I'm better
at not speaking over my guess but right
when I said that I spoke right over here
well that's a stupid [__] um there
was one I pulled on the Steve Aoki
podcast someone wrote like Stevo
actually shut up on this one and we got
to hear the guest talk and there are
times where you like I do see those
comments but see the thing is with with
pulling these comments is like it's
either stuff we've already talked about
like bam or Zach or the fact that you
talk over your guests or the video game
stuff like no one's like it was like you
you right like
you know okay Stevo and his whatever no
one's talking [__] on your skateboarding
yeah yeah I mean you could pull up a
comment right now see if you see
anything you don't like I'm not I'm not
worried about it I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna let that be yeah let's get into
some current events the current event
that I had that I wanted to talk to I
was listening on to a podcast on the way
here and they were talking about the uh
the SAG strike the rider strike and one
of the problems was
um the use of AI so oh my God you guys
see that [__] video that I sent you
about how gnarly deep fakes are gonna be
yeah gnarly but to get to that point so
that they reference at the end of the
movie Flash they they had an AI uh CGI
character that like used to be in an old
flash or whatever and the people uh
maybe that guy like the trust saw that
they're like well wait a minute he's on
the movie like is he is his likeness
getting paid for that and so I figured
the question is like okay so if they're
gonna start using Ai and the actor
doesn't have to be there for the movie
how much is it a licensing thing well I
I saw something that said that uh
like background actors
are getting paid
like for one day of work to film like a
thing that makes their likeness like in
perpetuity throughout the Universe
forever
like oh [__] so they're going to be
always in background I guess like an
extra if you're because people do like
kind of make a living or at least a
part-time living doing extra work but
now it's like you'll work one time and
like now we got you and we can use it
forever and they don't have to pay them
well but they must be signing something
right they said that uh that this one
tweet or something that I saw said that
um
like Bill Gates got paid every single
time somebody downloaded uh windows but
like a background actor gets paid one
day work for their stuff to be used as
like much many times forever
ever I mean but the paycheck's got to be
pretty big because no one in their right
one day of work no it's 160 bucks I mean
it's not big now yeah it should be cool
with the right mind is going to sign a
contract for 160. the [__] 78 pages
when you like sign something or you're
just like yeah if I get okay okay yeah
hey then you got to get a lawyer for
that my question to you is like one of
ten years down the road they used they
did film the jackass and they used AI to
do your character they're doing stunts
would how much would you want to get
paid from that it's like wait a minute I
mean that's but that's the argument it's
like you're saying the AI is doing the
stunt so there's just no Stakes there's
nothing yeah the jackass example doesn't
really work but if it was like Leo
DiCaprio in a movie but he doesn't have
to show up they just use an AI version
of Leo how much does he get paid like
that uh Black Mirror episode yeah
exactly Joan is awful yeah with uh Salma
Hayek yeah yeah I mean so like that's
the question is like okay they're
signing things like well you did sign
this in perpetuity they can use your
likeness that as a licensing is it five
percent temper like what do you do
yeah I think extras should be getting
paid for that obviously you shouldn't
just one day for like 60 bucks and then
they own you forever and they can use
you you know and have you get killed by
an alien in Spider-Man or whatever and I
don't know what else there the strike is
really about I know that the writers are
uh upset that the streamers are not
paying them
um like residuals for for streaming well
it's not only they don't pay you for
streaming because some people they do
like directors do get residuals from
Netflix but Netflix just says this is
what we owe you you can't audit Netflix
like there used to be uh companies like
the Nielsen ratings where they're a
third party company that is keeping an
eye on things and sending you what is
owed to you but this is Netflix just
saying you we owe you
a thousand bucks but you can't audit to
see the numbers of like how did you come
to that number how many views am I
getting what am I getting per view like
they don't you don't have that access to
info and like network television people
are getting residual checks for like 13
cents and they're like well like network
television is dead it's all about the
streaming services but they're not
paying residuals the CEOs are they said
for the year on these some of these CEOs
like what Bob Iger made 27 million
another guy in the last five years I
mean the top five made about three to
four hundred million each yeah in the
CEO position and they're like well
people aren't getting paid can you can
you look up how many people are on
strike right now because now the actors
are on streams
the actors and the writers are both on
strike and they said they haven't done
this since 1960 and I think there's a
171 000 people on strike but that's you
know how long is that going to go for
so the big picture is Strike by
Hollywood's largest Union which
encompasses 160 000 members in total
that's actors what about screenwriters
the the writers so that's actors joining
the writers on strike so now they can't
shoot any TV shows any movies they need
content so what are these big streaming
platforms going to do when they can't
well they're going to shoot more like
they're gonna just get more shows from
Korea and stuff like that like if you
see squid games like eight showing up
yeah they're not yeah Koreans aren't on
sag and yeah like it's just the US I
think that's striking and I read
something that uh Universal trimmed the
trees uh so the protesters didn't have
any shade while they were protesters oh
wow yeah so they're like now there's
like a whole investigation I mean I
think the streamers know what do they
can investigates they're trees yeah I
know there's this whole thing about it
it's pretty wild yeah it's [__]
Warfare dude yeah I think that's fair to
me I think the streamers know this can't
last forever like they will have to pay
residuals they will have to
like be auditable and show their numbers
to people and they're just holding on
for as long as they can because they're
making so much money and at the moment
they don't owe anybody's [__] well and
they said a lot of people these people
171 000 people or 160 000 people are out
of work so they said you know what do
they wait till their their third
mortgage payment is up and then go back
to the negotiating table see if they're
willing to because these people can't do
anything else because they're in part of
a union so like we've had the
conversation some people can't even come
on the podcast because they're in the
SAG and they can't talk about it so like
somebody uh suggested to me that I
should go to the the strike line or the
picket line whatever and and uh do
something or other you're a sag member
yeah yeah
um and and my response to this person
was that I really don't understand
quite what it's all about and I can't
help but feel that the
entertainment industry the conventional
you know mainstream industry just kind
of lost interest in me and now like I
identify as a digital
YouTuber an influencer guy a non-union
yeah I kind of identify more as a
digital guy
and then yeah and you kind of make your
own work like you're not waiting by the
phone for somebody to give you a job but
still like what happened with jackass
and Paramount plus was kind of probably
[__] and right should be maybe
illegal and like all this like everyone
working together to demand change so
that [__] like that doesn't happen
anymore but dude it's like not it's not
only that so you have all those people
on strike but what about the camera crew
what about the lightning crew like now
they're all out of work so it's a it's a
bigger the issue you know all these
people are out of work and so what
because they're in the union they can't
like start driving Uber or something you
could drive Uber but you can't do any
what your your trades in I wonder if
Uber prices will go down when jackass
was put to streaming were they telling
you the numbers on what it was getting
or
plus um
Paramount plus didn't exist when we did
our deals for the jackass movie
um and so it wasn't built into our
contracts that they could put it on
Paramount plus
that's how I understand it and um and
then when the movie came out they they
did not
take it to Netflix or to get
um an idea of the to market value
they just sold it to themselves
and they gave themselves a pretty good
deal
yeah yeah so we got kind of kind of
screwed out of that wasn't that what
they're striking for like now like I
guess I don't know yeah yeah I think
like actors it used to be like if you're
in an episode of The Cosby Show every
time that episode airs you're getting
paid it makes sense I'm I'm glad they're
striking I hope you're striking yeah I
just don't feel really you know
personally emotional about it
because but what about being I mean you
were pretty mainstream for years right
so you you don't think you have some
sort of like compassion for
yeah I mean I measure compassion yeah
but I just don't ever feel like I and
maybe this is why I should be supportive
of the strike because I I don't feel
like I was ever particularly looked out
for by the but you didn't get residuals
from the jackass TV show right
and you got [__] on jackass forever
I mean maybe I should be like more and
more you get residuals off Wild Boys
no that's so [__] crazy dude yeah
that is crazy yeah I don't get uh I
don't get anything
um so yeah maybe I should care and I'm
just an ignorant
now dick maybe go see what the fuss is
all about yeah okay so what other
current events doing so right now
there's like hearings happening in
Washington about UFOs UFOs
you know what else is out of this world
something inspired by NASA is my new
bedding from Miracle made and what makes
it so special is that it's silver
infused fabric that makes the bedding uh
regulated temperature that's better for
you to sleep at plus it precludes
bacteria from growing on your sheets I
mean you got like 99.9 of bacteria isn't
even messing with your sheets so less
disgusting a lot more comfortable and
better for your health and your sleep
that is Miracle made and it gets better
and better because if you go to try
miracle.com
Stevo not only can you get three free
towels but you're talking about 40 off
your order and like everything man and I
stand by this product dude Miracle made
bedding go to try miracle.com Stevo get
those three free towels and forty
percent off your order plus rest assured
that there's a 30-day money-back
guarantee they're so sure that you're
gonna love this bedding so nothing to
lose man get on over to trimirical.com
Stevo and let's get back to it
the government people are under oath
saying yes I mean yes there are crafts
yes we have biological entities like
aliens also who were piloting those
crafts and all of that exists and that
is happening right now under oath Tom
DeLonge tweeted I saw his tweet I was I
was right aliens exist
so is it a coincidence though that this
is the same day that the the Biden jury
or trial starts like are they trying to
cover up what's going on with like
the Biden it could be conveniently timed
for that like oh let's do it that day
but still this has been in the works for
a long time but it's always like when
something else is in the news they bring
up UFOs yeah did you notice that
everybody cares about UFOs so it's not
effective people are starting to care
I care about UFOs I mean it's one of the
biggest questions I can have so are
there biological entities Among Us like
uh that we see as humans but they're not
humans that I am not heard I mean I've
seen conspiracies on that that's of
course there's conspiracies on that but
but from I've only seen a little bit of
this footage of the trials but it was
just they're called
by biologics that that's what they're
calling non-human biologics so they're
not saying humanoid or human looking
things they're saying nothing about
walking Among Us or anything like that
they're just saying from what I saw
crafts have been recovered and there
were pilots of some of those crafts
which have also been recovered I didn't
hear anything it is non-human non-human
yes they identify as non-human they
identify as nonsense
are they mad at us
that I don't know but there was one
question like has there been any
violence like from them like towards the
people around and the guy said like yeah
there's been some like some of the stuff
me and my wife saw like what did he say
yeah he said I saw some disturbing
things that's what he said like in a
question referring to like have they
like hurt anybody in this process
um and uh there were people who were
murdered in a cover-up attempt I didn't
see anything about that yeah like what
are you talking about Google that
murdered by who's talking about Obama's
Chef that just died no no no no no no no
um I saw there's a headline that
um that people were murdered in UFO
cover-ups where or when
somebody would have been murdered Jesus
well okay so this is the guy who's on
trial the congressman as UFO
whistleblower if anyone has been
murdered to maintain alleged cover-up
and what did he say Tim Bush should ask
the government whistleblower whether he
believes anyone's been murdered blah
blah blah very very bottom right there
do you have any personal knowledge of
people who have been harmed or injured
in efforts to cover up and conceal these
extraterrestrials yes
replied personally
I mean has anyone been murdered he
hesitated for a moment he hesitated for
a moment before saying I have to be
careful asking that question he said
signing a current investigation whether
or not subject blah blah blah I directed
I directed people with that knowledge to
the appropriate authorities so so yes
that's sort of alluding to so he said
there's been murders
so it's this one guy who's like a
whistleblower but there's many of them
out there he's probably just the first
guy that's on trial but I feel like
there's been other people in front of
Congress talking about it
Dr David Greer
he's big
Lazar
but I don't think Bob lazar's ever
spoken in front of Congress he should
has he no I've just seen him on like
Rogan and stuff I guess so there's UFOs
what is that like mean how does that
affect my daily life
I don't know so you don't care at all
about aliens and UFOs then tell me why
UFOs big whoops
like tell me how that changes anything I
mean we're not alone in the universe
there's aliens that have landed on
planet Earth and they're here are they
mad at us I don't know I think they
don't know well they may affect your
life I mean they said they started
showing up when we started like
inventing nuclear bombs but you're
you're sort of complaining like
conspiracy theories and this like this
guy hasn't said that you're just saying
that's a general yes
Oppenheimer no not yet did you yeah I
was like it
whenever I watch a movie that's based on
a true story like I immediately turn
around and then watch the actual
documentary like or whatever and in the
case of Oppenheimer like sure when
they're like counting down like they're
blowing up the test bomb like that's
super intense it's like really eerie
when they have like the box set bombs
that are being sent to go bomb Japan
that that's super crazy
um but overall I kind of felt like it
was just uh I I wasn't really getting it
I was like man I can't wait to get home
and watch like a more like easy to
digest
true story about it did you see Barbie
I did not see Barbie Barbie blew it out
of the water huh yeah Barbie killed it
yeah
would you give Oppenheimer out of one to
a hundred
I didn't think it was that great man I I
like it just never grabbed you you never
really gave a [__] like it felt like the
full three hours it didn't feel like a
full three hours but I was just like ah
with the artisticness you know like just
tell me the story I mean how was Cillian
Murphy
silly was he a silly boy yeah he was
it was kind of cool that he spoke with
an American accent but he did it kind of
weird I don't know
silly and Murphy I want to love like
Robert Downey Jr like all all of it
and I'm mad at it I'm not saying it was
bad so you wouldn't recommend it was
that great did you see Barbie no no no
not yet not yet yeah I'm probably gonna
go see it what can I say I wanted to
love the movie about the guy who made
the atomic bomb because sometimes I drop
atomic bombs in the toilet I'm talking
about big sloppy dumps and I'm so happy
to be back at home because in my house
on every toilet is my bidet from Hello
tushy when I get done taking a huge dump
I got a little knob and I turned that
knob and next thing you know I got a
it's like pressure cleaning my butthole
a stream of just blasting cleanliness
and freshness onto my butthole and it
cuts down toilet paper use by 80 it
makes your butthole totally clean man
imagine like you're gonna take a dump
and then use dry toilet paper it's just
like smearing poop around no no no with
hello tissue bidets you're blasting your
butthole completely clean and it's my
favorite dude it's so satisfying if
you've never tried it you're out of your
mind it's time to get one and if you go
to
hellotushy.com
Stevo and use the promo code Stevo then
you're gonna get 10 off your first bidet
purchase plus free shipping it's
incredible man and they're so confident
you're gonna love it plus I'm so
confident you're gonna love it hello
tushy has a 60-day risk-free money back
guarantee how about that if you've never
blasted your butthole with the product
from hellotushy.com it's time to go
there hello tishy.com devote and use the
promo code Stevo for 10 off plus free
shipping your butthole is gonna thank me
now let's get back to it I mean in other
news I went to the UCLA Medical Examiner
today yeah you got a finger up your butt
I got a finger on my butt did you guys
get checked now it was horrible
have you ever had it I mean because he's
like okay you ready to knuckle deep and
you're just like which knuckle
that's probably the point I don't know
well he probably does two fingers I
didn't like it he put in one finger and
he said
no you're just like and then you see
white but you guys you guys see white I
mean yeah dude it's like dude if you're
if you're having foreplay it's like
you're you're you're [__] the
butthole you're working your way in
you'll just go into the [__] I mean
she just goes right in so you want him
to tickle it a little bit first
yeah I mean delicious would just do a
little bit of foreplay though it
wouldn't hurt as much was he moved up
yeah I mean bro what kind of your
buttholes dilated to 10 like a [__]
pregnant lady every I mean dude you saw
what we put up there I mean come on if
it took Time Imagine just going straight
in it's gonna be like so he just goes
in Scott like trying to like oh yeah it
was so bad yeah I'm not gay
but you it's not a pleasure
you've had a prostate examination and it
wasn't a big deal I blacked out can
anybody in the comments like talk about
that it was painful or not but anyway so
so after they did all the test they uh I
have high cholesterol and I was like
talking about losing weight I already
have results and it was today dude it
was like the most [__] while his
fingers in there he's like oh yeah
cholesterol hold on yeah oh yeah it's
high yeah blood pressure no he got it
today and I was like talking about
weight loss and he's like dude the
secret he's like the to weight loss is
he's like if you keep your diet under
1900 calories a day and you don't go
above 150 grams of carbs he's like
you'll lose weight that's what Vinnie
does no he doesn't he says he does that
I we were on the bus and he's like dude
I just I can't understand why I'm not
losing weight as he's eating the sixth
bag of monster Munch and he's like I
think I have a thyroidism
it's a it's but I so that was
interesting but it's scary you know with
having high cholesterol and [__] like
that so
I don't know so you didn't like the
finger up the bus okay
it's not pleasurable to go up with a
latex glove you haven't had my finger
you have a small little finger yeah and
then I was like talking to Paul about
like you know like do you ever get
checked out you know he's like he's like
nah what's the point and then I and then
I were talking about going to the
dentist he's like dude I haven't been to
the dentist in a long time he's like
last time I went I had 13 cavities no
last time I went one time when I went I
never go to the doctor like I have I
don't get like a physical once a year I
haven't got a physical in years same
dude like uh I don't go to the dentist
I'm not like against it I just hate well
I don't know I'm not like morally
against it I'm just lazy to like book
appointments and go but you could yearly
checkups right ah
I don't know when the last time I got a
yearly checkup was but I go to the
dentist every three months for cleaning
for the cleaning yeah but I mean do 13
cavities so one time I went to the
dentist and he was like wow yeah you
have 13 cavities yeah but I don't know I
don't know why that is I think my bones
just like are falling apart like I don't
eat like candy or anything like that I
don't know I brush my teeth I floss I'm
just falling apart from the inside
turning into Ash yeah and are you
getting your teeth done I have an
appointment for my X-ray tomorrow
getting them done
no eventually yeah like what what are
you getting done with them everything
fixed may be replaced oh yeah that's
right is that with our guy that we uh
doctor yeah so you got like big tooth
problems uh yeah oh yeah for sure I'm
terrified but yeah I have an x-ray
appointment tomorrow
um I'm stoked so when you're doing it
here in L.A and you're just transmitting
the x-rays to Dr Brady yeah exactly we
we uh
told Vinnie that we're gonna help him
with his teeth problems and he started
crying he's oh yeah that's cute you did
I know dude I was trying hard not to let
you [__] see it like I was like in the
other room and you're just like walking
by like and meanwhile I forgot all about
that and like when I watched we're still
doing it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
might get like veneers yeah yes you made
a generous donation to the cause yeah I
made that donation yet yeah oh I did
cool yeah no it's a good thing like it's
a it's a good cause because what these
people do is they help out like people
with like teeth and teeth issues are a
big thing for people yeah I mean it's a
big insecurity yeah when you called me
into the Green Room that night when you
when you like offered that you're like
all right Vinnie come sit down I was
like oh [__] what did I do you know all
right and then you're like so you uh
told Scott your deepest darkest Secrets
huh I was like wait what the [__] am I
don't like what the [__] did I say and
he's like dude I'll pay for your teeth
man and I was just like Sabe because no
one's ever offered anything like that to
me you know so I was like yeah it's like
the yeah it's just what I donated like
10 000. yeah
yeah
thanks I mean let me die I love you too
dog
I don't think of someone with like bad
teeth yeah it's like it's gnarly back
there okay yeah what is that from crack
cocaine a lot of smoking crack your
teeth like that not smoking crack
yeah yeah heroin doesn't make your teeth
fall out oh heroin because when you're
high on heroin you you crave sweets so
it's like I'm eating a lot of sugar too
but why crack crack you're just smoking
[__] whatever's on crack I don't know
cracking crack I just smoke it cracks
your teeth yeah wow I mean Meth mouth
that's a thing right is it meth hurt
your mouth too is it your teeth or it
like messes up your skin
messes up I've just heard the term Meth
mouth
yeah right you uh like math time uh I
didn't like it but I did it yeah I never
turned it down I never turned it down
that's a fact did you smoke crack ever
Steve I never smoke crack
not uh
with all the boiling and like what about
smoking Coke
yeah I mean I would like put Coke on
cigarettes but it's not just wasted so
yeah it's a waste of drugs there's
nothing you get nothing I got higher
than a [__] Georgia Pine after
smoking a lot of coke did you ever smell
crack yeah
that's pretty cool did you like it yeah
yeah like I don't want to smoke crack
but I'm jealous that you guys like did
in the past smoke crack you know what to
say like I I woke up and like I had bit
the entire [__] like bottom half of
my life just chewing my lips met my
first time that I was in rehab was
1995. my mom like uh said she wouldn't
bail me out of jail unless I went to
rehab and how old were you then I was 20
okay still not 21. yeah so I go to rehab
when I'm 20 years old and like
every day somebody comes and somebody
leaves there's like Turner for sure and
like generally we're always in like the
circle of feelings you're everyone's
sitting in a big circle sharing their
feelings and somebody comes
and they introduce themselves to the
circle and they say what's their drug of
choice
and I noticed that when people said
their drug of choice was crack cocaine
people are just like that they've
considered the person a write-off yeah
like like no no eye contact that
person's not my roommate I would like
you know like that that I just noticed
there was something about crack cocaine
that was like really really different
from Powder cocaine because somebody
said their drug of choice was powder
cocaine it was almost like snickering
like what a [__] you know like heaven
forbid if somebody walked in and said
their drug of choice was marijuana they
would be like yeah it's like the Half
Baked they would be like unsafe in there
like so there's like a hierarchy of drug
addicts it's like it's like high school
with clicks you know what I mean like
when people hang out yeah and listen to
the Grateful Dead if People's drug of
choice was heroin it was like they were
just like carried in oh we'll meet them
in a couple days
really yeah yeah what do you mean we'll
meet them in a couple days just because
out of commission they were out of
commission like they were uh you know
the other detox we're like the cool kids
at rehab like which drug group is the
coolest
um like the I would say heroin of course
yeah
I I was just I my whole take on it was
just that I was like such a a rinky dink
you know like just being there at the
time made me feel like dude
yeah what were you in there for just
like a DUI why yeah I was there for uh
alcohol well you were doing coke and
stuff barely so you felt like I'm not
even really a drug addict this is just
right did you know when you get out
you're just gonna get high again when
you're in there are we really trying to
put your best foot forward
but I was like just kind of clueless
about it like I mean I went to a sober
living and then I was just like all
right dude I had my buddy Kevo like
bring me weed to this really living yeah
I was smoking weed and sober living did
you ever talk about the the thing that
you and Kevo got into where like
somebody saved your guys's life I don't
think you've talked about that on this
where the glass was broken and you guys
were bleeding out that wasn't Kevin that
was my buddy Canyon what happened it was
uh it's a gnarly [__] deal dude it
was after graduating high school I was
uh like just turned 18 years old my
buddy Canyon and I like uh we were like
gnarly Drinkers and we just had like he
had like a bottle of Jack Daniels and we
filled these huge Brandy glasses like
and just chugged
like chugged huge glasses of whiskey we
automatically both blacked out
and um there was a in his house there
was this glass door which he like
clearly like he fell
through the glass door landed on like
Jagged glass sticking up from the bottom
and it cut his elbow like through all
like tendons and everything and we were
just both like
blacked out like passed out and uh the
only reason why Canyon didn't die from
bleeding out is because the neighbor
heard the glass break and thought that
they were hearing a break-in so they
called the cops the cops showed up and
found us just laying in this gnarly pool
of blood like it was the gnarliest
bloodbath like I was just you know you
were out I wasn't even injured I was
just out
I was yeah I was just out and um
so they're called the ambulance like um
you know he homeboy like was so there
was more blood than I've ever seen
because I went I went to his house like
the next day to get stuff for him and
bring it to him in the hospital weed
hail white more blood than I've ever
seen anywhere dude it was the gnarliest
and um so they got us into uh an
ambulance took us both to the hospital
like he needed surgery but he was too
drunk so they were just kind of like uh
stabilizing him I'd like uh was just so
drunk they put me on an IV to uh you
know it's just like alcohol poisoning
yeah I mean it was pretty it was pretty
serious and um like uh I I I I
ripped out my IV I'm like I'm gonna like
we're breaking out where's my buddy and
I'm like uh I think they said I was like
trying to punch nurses or something like
uh but but like doing a really poor job
of it right like the ever you know and
and uh I remember they were like
they got the cuts back on me again and
and and the next memory that I think I
had was I was back in the Paddy Wagon
the cops were telling me look if you go
back into the hospital to try to break
your friend out again we're gonna have
to really actually lock you up in jail
like you're like being a bro but you're
also not because your body needs like
medical attention but you're like I'm
Gonna Save you out of here it's like
he's not in jail he's not being fixed
right and uh and so then this Paddy
Wagon with with me and like uh they uh
take me to my take me home and and um
they bring the doorbell my mom comes in
the door opens up the door and it's her
son like just cross-eyed covered in
blood I mean like I was like the gnarly
is just covered from laying in a pool of
blood and with a police officer on
either side a British Bobby and they're
like this is your son she's just like
shaking her head like what did she say
when the door shut like I mean I like it
there were there were a number of
episodes like that
and for you when you wake up the next
day are you like that was rad are you
like [__] I gotta go save him I gotta go
get him out like where's your head at do
you feel bad about it you feel like I
mean it like I I recognized that like
that was you know a life and death
situation yeah you know I wasn't stoked
on it like I I I knew that every time I
chugged liquor like there was bad like
chugging straight hard liquor like
always ended up it's a bad thing there
was a time before that okay I just drive
I used to ride my bicycle around London
everywhere you know that was my thing
and the the time before that that I
chugged hard liquor
um I woke up on the hood of a parked car
like I was just riding my bicycle and
just straight wrote it and head on into
a parked car
like landed on the hood and I had my
front teeth broken what yeah like I
broke my front teeth they were like I
don't even remember like getting home I
never remembered getting home just the
next day and I wasn't even that close to
home but the next day my bike was in an
unrideable condition just sitting in
like the the entrance the in the front
doorway of the house it's mangled which
is pretty mangled like I have evidently
like I don't know maybe somebody helped
me get home maybe I carried the bike
home no recollection or any of it and uh
two broken you're like okay next time I
chug liquor I'll wear a helmet or
something like that when did you think
when did you know you had a problem
um
was it like then or was it first time
when like I really read like I have a
problem I should do something about it
was
um like after I got uh placed on Final
disciplinary probation
um like within two weeks of class
starting at the University of Miami you
thought you had a drug problem yeah I
mean they rated my room and like you
know that early on huh yeah yeah I was
18 years old what'd they find in your
room just a bunch of like you know they
have these huge laundry hampers that are
like on wheels that like they've filled
one of those up with uh like empty beer
cans and other alcohol bottles like uh
basically yeah like it was a lot you
know it was a lot and um
and they found like a bunch of weed too
and when did you start doing acid I
started doing acid when I was 16. they
didn't find any acid then or no no I
didn't find any acid then so all the way
already at 18 you're like I'm a drug
addict I have a problem I wasn't as
concerned about drugs it was mostly
alcohol yeah and when I was 18
um I I it was this is so crazy I was I
was like man like I I remember looking
up Alcoholics Anonymous in uh in the
phone book and there it was I found the
number and that gave me a sense of
accomplishment so I didn't call it
yeah I mean there it is who's going to
be there crossed that up the old list
there's the help I need it yeah and uh
and and so but rather than call A A what
I what I decided was I said I'm gonna go
for 30 days
and and not drink you know I'm not gonna
drink for 30 days and then that's gonna
show me that like I have control and
like you know I'm gonna do that to prove
to myself and man the second I started
this 30 days no drinking
kind of like when you go on a diet and
then all of a sudden all you can think
about is food for sure because you're on
a diet now you're extra obsessed with
just thinking about food so all you know
like all I could think about was just
how bad I wanted to be drinking and that
I wasn't drinking I was just obsessed
with it and that was like shotgunning
like cans of coke and stuff like it was
like silly like that's like Vinnie's
shooting up water yeah he's trying to
quit right yeah
crazy I was so obsessed with it and I
tried I tried and I tried and then uh
I only made it 12 days I was gonna say
okay I made it 12 days and then what I
did was uh I did a shot of VOD got like
one of these Point 1.75 liter bottles of
crappy vodka and I did a shot and then I
did a shot I did 12 shots in a row to
commemorate the 12 days of surprise yeah
I did I did I did I did one shot for
each of the 12 days to unadmit that
there was a problem
because because what I should have done
in my view was drink all of it I should
never even came up with that dumb idea
that was a mistake it was a mistake I
drank a shot for each day so your clean
slate yeah you're right it's clean so
you didn't feel like oh man I couldn't
even make it 30 days I I knew I knew
clearly that yeah okay and that was that
was uh like
a year and a half or so before I was in
rehab but for drug addiction this is
like you wake up in the morning and like
during the day you're like [__] I'm a
drug addict and then at night you're
like okay let's do some drugs I'm like
you're having fun again right and then
it's just like the cycle right like
that's sure it's not like you were 12
years then of just like feeling like a
drug addict right it's exactly it's
exactly yeah the cycle of addiction you
know like
you've got the the
remorse period you know they've got the
like uh were you waking up and drinking
because I was like waking up and being
like okay don't drink till five and then
it was like all right [__] don't drink
till one all right don't drink till 12.
like were you were you drinking all day
were you trying to like be good during
the day
we're like I was like smoking weed
during the day and yes I was drinking
when I woke up but there wasn't as much
of the you know more like smoke weed
when I wake up and was there ever a
point where you were just so physically
dependent on it where if you didn't
drink you would have the shakes or I
don't remember much of that DTS yeah not
for any drug like did you have like Coke
withdrawals or anything like that
um
that's not really a thing with Coke yeah
okay I'm just like clearly don't really
I thought like I remember Elton John
talking about like he he couldn't eat
without doing a line of coke or
something like that like
the other way around
like he couldn't wake up without doing
it I mean what definitely if I had Coke
like if I did align a Coke then I
immediately needed a drink because
otherwise yeah take the edge off it's
like as soon as I did a shot of coke I
immediately needed a shot of heroin yeah
to come down yeah yeah right do a line
of coke and then I gotta have a drink
and if I have a drink then where's the
coconut yeah
like when you were when you were living
at home were you trying to hide your
your drinking in drug use or was it
pretty out in the open when I was living
in a wet like in high school yeah or
like uh I remember I remember taking it
like a heavy head of acid like tripping
my face off like uh I took it at school
and I came home and and uh like ate
dinner with my mom whoa like playing it
off like I wasn't tripping my face off
I don't think she knew I don't think she
knew what was that like and there was
another time
when my sister and I moved from
Albuquerque to uh Florida and we packed
up the the house into a U-Haul trucks
we're driving from the park in New
Mexico to Florida
and right before I get in the U-Haul
truck to start this drive my buddy Kirby
gave me a bunch of mushrooms and I like
I I ate like I was tripping so hard like
confined in the shotgun seat with my
sister and she didn't know I was
tripping and like we were for hours what
were you all doing she's like all right
your turn to drive
I mean you you could hold it together
like that with my sister or were you
just like
well I remember I never really liked
mushrooms because like I I I would just
get too introspective like and by
introspective I mean like I would just
analyze myself and like arrive at the
conclusion that I'm just a drug addict
but just that just I'm just not rad like
I would just be like I would just I
would just really really criticize
myself and and just arrive at the
conclusion that I had sucked and nothing
that I was doing was worthy like I was
just like I've become very mean to
myself on mushrooms but not acid
acid
um not as much no
see for me with mushrooms it's like
I get real honest with myself not like
mean necessarily but like I can't like
trick myself into thinking something
that's not like real you know like if
I'm like being shitty to somebody then I
take mushrooms it's like
it's like dude you're being a bad friend
or something like that you can't hide
from it I can't pretend is this how you
felt like last week
was that being a bad friend no no no no
no I'm saying like you take mushrooms
all the time like right now for example
when's the last time you eat mushrooms
uh I mean this morning I ate a little
bit seriously are you serious yeah but
just like a little bit
well like not every day but I'll go on
like multi-day
just I don't take days off
what's the benefit from micro dosing
that frequent I don't know I don't go to
the doctor once a year but he'll eat
mushrooms they say there are medical
benefits to taking mushrooms it's good
for the brain for things like that and
chipping balls right now
I never trip like at most if I like take
a little too more than I wanted then
I'll like get kind of a body high and
I'm like whoa but um some days do you
think oh I kind of feel like taking a
little extra today yeah some days I go a
little more you know I overdose myself a
little bit but it's always like a pretty
micro trip so then why do it
like because there's a benefit
supposedly to micro dosing on mushrooms
like there's benefits to the brain and
like the psyche and maybe I feel it a
little bit it's like an antidepressant
too it just feels good I don't know
maybe I feel it just wow I like it I
feel like the back half of this podcast
was better than the first half yeah
we're really cooking now yeah
um so you're uh on drugs and and um
but I I [__] love you man I love when
we do this and we've got the gorgeous
pop risky effect I love you guys too
yeah dude and uh do we have anything
else do we want to talk about how epic
your special was yeah this is our first
time all together since Europe dude
there was [__] badass it went as good
as it could go huh yeah dude it was so
sick like now that you've had time since
it hot like I mean there's nothing you
would have changed right like it was
perfect ever since then I find myself at
some point in the day like thinking
dude that that was actually real like it
actually
it happened like that it was that badass
I was so nervous about only having the
two shows it was perfect we hadn't put
on this that we had added the Thursday
and it just wasn't you know I was like
[__] this Show's not going to sell out
and
there's no way that stage would have
been ready I know it would have put so
much stress on making sure everything
was ready by then it just was impossible
so so we turned off that Thursday show
and we yeah
um and and we pulled it off in two shows
it's pretty sick dude I can't wait to
see a cut of it and then so last night
you did a set at the Hollywood first set
starting from zero putting together your
next hour my first set starting from
zero on what would be the gone too far
tour how did you feel about that
I felt like I was unprepared and what do
you want you know you just gotta put
yourself into the fire I mean I had
enough to talk about and just kind of a
big picture view of what the show is got
a great joke out of it about uh the um
on the gun part which joke was that the
one where where it was like uh ruined a
perfectly good bit
yeah yeah right right I had no yeah that
was funny yeah that was nothing that I'd
ever even that came out of that yeah
that's true should we even say what that
joke was yeah but yeah that's true there
was like that's the beauty of it like
you know that's at least how I
approached it when I was doing stand-up
opening for you is like when I try to
tell a story to my friends like I always
try to get a laugh just naturally I'm
trying to be funny so like go up there
talk like your instincts to like make
them laugh will kind of lead you to
finding the jokes right and what I need
to do is find the story in the overall
arcing you know like from the story for
the whole show right and um
where I was imagining that the the whole
story was it was of me confronting
middle age I'm thinking more that it's a
story about uh
about pushing things further and how
that the conflict isn't between me and
middle age the conflict is between me
and my loved ones and uh how they view
it and what their arguments are for each
bit for me to not go through with it and
ultimately how when my loved ones try to
convince me to not do a bit what they
don't realize is that they're
reinforcing my belief that this bit is
actually epic you know the more people
try to convince me not to do something
the more attractive that bit is to me
and I think that in in each bit like the
arguments that were presented against
during the bit
and the relationship with my loved ones
and how they're dealing with me carrying
out the bits I think is more The Arc
than the middle age
yeah
I like that and you're also put like not
just your loved ones but like Society
you know like testing like right how far
can I push this right are we gonna find
the only way to find the line is to
cross it that's what Hunter S Thompson
said yeah so so yeah it's exciting and
the the process begins
I'm stuck yeah dude super sick all right
man well I [__] love you guys dudes
yeah
that's cool
and wouldn't you know it that after we
recorded this podcast just earlier today
I find a response from bam to my
response
and get a load of this
morning
oh my skateboarding is not
my skateboarding is not pleasing to
Bam's eye huh
bam that's uh that hits me right here
it's a personal attack and uh
I I don't know what to say bam like I
think that my skateboarding is actually
a lot like my tattoos you know like when
I give people tattoos not the best
tattoos but for some reason people love
my tattoo I do I give better tattoos
than you'd expect and I'm better at
skateboarding than you would expect
people want my boards they're buying
them so I'm sorry bam there's nothing I
can do to make you feel better
I'm selling skateboards and they're
available at stevo.com and and now we've
got the crispanius and Stevo double
signed collab skateboard the wild board
so suck on that bam go buy one at
stevo.com
foreign